hey theo this is ryan um
i want to get your thoughts on what it
means that uh
you know the ufos are definitely real
now and like whether that
kind of i don't know affects us as human
beings uh makes you think about
you know time travel and stuff like that
um
just in general doesn't impact your your
daily thinking that you can
you know look up at the sky and say
what's out there
all right buddy thanks a lot again
thank you for the call ryan you know
recently they had a thing
an article and it said uh
israeli space security chief
says extraterrestrials exist and trump
knows about it
he said a galactic federation has been
waiting for humans to reach a stage
where we will understand
what space and spaceships are hayim
eshed has said this
said the aliens were equally curious
about humanity
and were seeking to understand the
fabric of the universe
and he said that they have been waiting
until today for humanity to develop
and reach a stage where we will all
understand in general what space
and spaceships are
they also added that president donald
trump was aware of the
extraterrestrial's existence
and had been on the verge of revealing
information
but was asked not to in order to prevent
mass hysteria according also to the
report uh haims
uh the former head of israeli's defense
ministry space
directorate told an israeli newspaper
that earthlings have been in contact
with a galactic federation and that
there is an underground base in the
depths of
mars where there are american astronauts
and
alien representatives
look you know to answer your question
ryan you said that we know now that
they're real
we i don't know i don't know if i
believe any news that comes out anymore
it's
all subject to what you believe
so i think the news used to be you know
there was a level of
what we thought was reality of it to it
and i don't know if that's the case
anymore i really don't
um so do i know if this article's legit
i have no idea
you think that there's like a board me
it makes it sound like there's a meeting
every year and the aliens decide
if we're ready to see the aliens
i don't know that sound like they're
like well how's this year been and
you're like well um
you know uh well we you know we're
arriving at the ps5 right now
and there is we have picture frames that
can change the picture
you know and they're solar powered so
we're you know we're still struggling to
recycle but uh
that's where we're at and then it's like
rejected
and then the next year they're like are
you how all right guys how's things this
year you ready to accept aliens
and they're like well we're having like
a lot of widespread racial disputes and
um
but we do you know there is a new
popular like bidet
attachment that people are buying for
their toilets they don't have to wipe
their butt
it's like uh rejected
dude it reminds me of that scene in um
shawshank redemption where he keeps
going every year to try to get
denied denied denied denied and then
finally
brooks was here baby i'mma kill myself
by the grocery
praise god baby um
so yeah that just seems weird that
there's a meeting every year
and that there's like discussion i just
can't
until people are ready we will
never be ready
people are beating the [ __ ] out of each
other for ps5s
at and the malls aren't even open
think about that there are
shooting i'm sure there's a shooting
right now if you put your ear up to a
bowl of dirty water
you can hear a shooting in flint
michigan right now
probably for a pair of children's arola
skates
we are not ready for aliens
now some positives i think is it would
give us all somebody to battle against
because i'll tell you straight up bro
some alien shows up over there in
memphis or something
some brother's gonna pop him off bro
real talk
or if he shows up out there in oregon a
couple of white dudes gonna sneak over
and abduct his ass you know
make a chili out of them
so i i don't know i mean
i mean the whole the alien thing always
to me do i think that we're the only
people
here like the only beings i don't know
and people say well it's selfish to
think that well
i don't think it i don't know
i think we're in the very tender years
of learning about all of that kind of
stuff
the simple fact that we're still
operating on fuels like uh
you know gasoline and um
whatever else they're using octane
i think in the future people will be
able to [ __ ] travel on a good idea
you know
you'll have a couple good ideas and
that'll fill up your idea cube and then
you'll
be able to use the lightning created
from that to
migrate to different areas i think you
know we're just on this we're on this
very
novice plane right now
so yeah i think uh it's going to be
interesting down
down the line now i do think this about
aliens i think it's wild that
aliens always trying to get in
everybody's booty and body
everybody that gets abducted by aliens
they trying to [ __ ] them bro
i mean who are the you know what i'm
saying
or aliens just a bunch of like just
dudes like bunch of drunk dudes in vegas
or something
because every time they pick somebody up
the first thing they tell people is they
try to
touch you know you know touch inside
their booties
and that makes me sad bruh but
but that's aliens man i'm just sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been